Okay.
Our business focuses us on diversity
because we all work in a sport that was
deemed too black to thrive and actually
even survive.
People Forget.
But there were articles,
the dark clouds over the NBA,
you know,
mirror.
I had,
I literally,
when I was executive vice president,
Larry sent me up to a newspaper and the,
uh,
the television guy said,
you don't get it stern.
You guys are just not going to make it.
This is a white country and you have a
black sport.
So we developed chips on our shoulder
early on.
If you worked at the NBA in the 70s,
you had to be a believer that America
was a good country and that we had
something to teach rather than to be
afraid of a sport,
you know,
that could have Willis Reed from
Louisiana and grambling and the bill
Bradley from a Crystal City,
Missouri and Princeton on a championship
team.
Hmm.
That says something about a sport that
has something to teach that's about,
that's about talent.
We sort of rallied around the notion
that if you came to an NBA game,
it didn't matter where you sat,
you know,
whether you were in the nosebleed
section or at court side,
your opinion counted.
And regardless of your race,
and if you were on the court,
you're,
your talent counted regardless of your
race.
You got game,
you play,
you don't have game,
you don't.
And so this was a subject of some
discussion at the NBA always on an
ongoing basis.
And it has ramifications throughout our
whole business.
When I was,
uh,
required to act when Ron,
our test,
uh,
ran into the stands in Detroit and there
was a big brawl,
et Cetera,
the talk radio that weekend,
you,
the words thugs and punks was uttered
what seem to be about a million times,
I'm sure it was less,
but we will know the code words.
And,
and so we're,
we tend to be particularly protective of
our players in that regard.
And I think it makes us conscious of a
lot of different things,
uh,
having to do with the racial discussion.